all right from Key areas to key moments
I think we can bring in some live
pictures now coming in from uscodile
where the president
erdogan is casting his Vote or turning
up at that makeshift polling station to
cast his vote Cinema is there let's
bring her back into the picture and I
know you may have a little bit going on
around you right now synonym but picking
up on the point which Alexi was talking
about key areas one of those key areas
of course is the arbucker where you've
been spending some time talk us through
the Dynamics playing out in areas like
there between the nationalists and
Kurdish vote
well yes Sami by the way president
just arrived I'm just moving aside so
that you can see clearly he is getting
inside the school to cast his ballot
he's here with the first lady and an
hour earlier his younger son arrived
here to cast his vote with his wife and
uh always you know when President Ardon
is here there is a cheerful crowd
chanting for him as this area is his uh
one of his
vote base and coming back to your
question in the Arbuckle we spent the
last couple of days out there dear
Booker is known as the capital for the
Kurdish politics and for the Kurdish
culture and it is one of the 11 cities
that was affected by the earthquake and
we have spoken to so many people there
they some of them really want to change
and a the art Booker votes for the pro
Kurdish party however during the first
round they voted for Kamal College
terolo the main opposition candidate
because the pro Kurdish party would
joined the election under a different
Banner this time announced its support
for kamakulus however there is a game
changer here not only for president
erdon's Alliance but also for the
opposition candidate
because both sides have pro-kurdish
parties in their alliances but after the
first round as synonym the third
candidate who received an unexpected
vote of 5.2 percent is now split between
the two sides they are trying to grab
the nationalismos which were the new
king makers of the second round and
there are there are a few nationalist
parties in Turkey Asami and when you
when you calculate when you add up their
whole votes it's about about 25 percent
so besides the Kurdish votes that are
nearly 16 million people that
constitutes
20 percent of the whole population in
Turkey now you have the national dispose
as the king makers it is a very
difficult task for president erdogan and
his Challenger came out to strike a
balance between those two sides because
they are against each other because
those far-right parties support the
Crackdown on Pro Kurdish politicians and
when you speak to Kurdish people in the
region they feel offended they're upset
because every consolation process that
was launched by The Rolling Out party
under President erdon's Reign was
officially withheld in 2015 though they
started to solve the problems in the
region but now they are backing the
Republican Party main opposition party
leader kamakulus who is known to be that
part is known to be oppressing the
Kurdish rights Banning their media so
there are so many things that you can
call as the first time but of course for
the Kurds they are concerned about the
far rights potential influence on
chemical serola if it comes to power
because chemical cholesterol promises
freedom but that King maker nationalist
was they are in favor of the Crackdown
on the pro Kurdish politicians some of
them are already in prison some of them
uh have been their MP their
parliamentary seats have been ripped off
so this is a challenge how cliche or or
erdogan is going to act is unknown
everything is going to be clear after
the results today but in two care things
change very quickly you you would never
expect a brokerage party align with the
Republican party but they're aligned in
the presidential run now you have a
far-right party that is allying with
that Alliance so everything is full of
surprises in Turkey this is what I have
to underline Sami
foreign
going through the process of casting his
his valet having his ID checked uh
getting his voter card and word has just
reached me that almost exactly in the
same moment in another city anchor of
the capital of Turkey
the leader of the opposition and the
opposition candidate for the presidency
well guess what he was doing
casting his ballot at the Argentinian
school there almost perfectly
choreographed or coordinated at the same
time and I guess it's just another
visual reminder of how much of a of a
head-to-head is happening here between
these two very different candidates
but we are hearing some people
especially among the opposition are
already disappointed some of them told
us that they don't want to go to the
ballots but both sides both the
governing side and the opposition side
are urging their supporters to go to the
ballot boxes to show their will but of
course this is a neck and neck this was
a neck and neck situation in the first
round now this is a neck and neck
because both sides are trying to grab
those 5.2 percent votes and even that
National far-right nationalist Alliance
is now split between erdon and Kalisto
Rollo so which leader is it sinanuan the
third candidate or um
who let that alliance with his Ultra
nationalist rhetoric and discourses
especially his anti-refugee
discourses will drive will mobilize
those Far Right
Far Right borders support is unknown so
we don't know whether that's 5 5.2
percent from the first round really
belong to sinaloan or the secularist
scandalous
formed fraction that is represented by
um that's why still everything is naked
neck despite erdogan was five points
ahead of K Michel in the first round
we don't know indeed synonym thank you
so much for your reporting there from us
godal but we might just start to know or
get indications after 1400 GMT 5 PM
local time the high Election Commission
says it's going to meet and review and
decide whether or not it's going to
allow media organization to start
reporting on some of the results and
indications of results so we'll be here
our special coverage will continue for
now I'm going to hand you back to Doha
Sammy cinem in Istanbul thank you very
much we've just been watching the live
pictures of what's probably one of the
highlights of the day so far the
incumbent president redshift type
erdogan voting and his rival uh darulu
also voting just moments ago